moi comme je te connais très bien je
pense ne pas trop m'avancer en me disant
que j'ai assez vite compris la séquence
c'est-à-dire je laisse la politique à
ceux qui ont parlé très bien tout à
l'heure mais sinon pour le reste je
crois que c'est juste que ce garçon est
arrivé ce jeune garçon est arrivé tu
l'aimes bien tu l'as fait démarrer ici
et il va commencer ici il était un petit
peu dans l'équipe et puis quand
forcément quand tout d'un coup il a
commencé à sortir des propos qui t'ont
qui t'ont enfin voilà qui sont un peu
heurté tu t'es senti trahi et pour ceux
qui ne connaissent un petit peu comme
nous tu es un peu excessif dans tout
dans dans l'amour dans l'émotion dans la
blague dans les colères et tout ça tu
t'es senti trahi quand on trahi par un
ami bah forcément on s'énerve et c'est
là que c'est parti pour moi c'est pour
ça que j'ai pas vu beaucoup de
politiques ce weekend moi moi ce que
j'ai vu c'est juste de l'émotion ou tu
t'es sorti trahi par quelqu'un que tu
aimais bien point barre et ça a donné
une engueulade ou c'est monté entre deux
mecs qui sont un peu sanguins j'ai pas
vu grand chose de plus pour dire la
vérité et je trouve qu'après ça a pris
des proportions qui m'ont complètement
échappé alors je vous donnerai mon avis
tout à l'heure bien sûr surtout de la
séquence Jean-Marie tu voulais réagir
parce que c'est pour non non non non
moi je trouve que tu as été plutôt
vachement bien parce que tu as mis du
temps moi j'ai cru que tu allais
l'ampleur très beaucoup plus tard
ou alors ou alors même ou même je
t'aurais bien vu lui dire mais je t'ai
pas insulté pauvre [ __ ]
de mettre un petit truc drôle dedans ça
aurait atténuer un peu la tension mais
tu as été vachement bien bon tu l'as
insulté tu tu la regretté tu l'as dit il
t'a dit je m'excuse
pas non j'ai juste voilà je veux dire
tout à l'heure
vraiment je ne m'insulte je m'excuse pas
du tout et je vous dis je regrette pas
du tout mais les énervé comme ça après
lui après c'est voilà les propos
injurieux comme
Géraldine mais bon voilà question pense
on va prendre Bernard qui était pas là
tiens bon alors moi j'étais pas là mais
j'ai vu évidemment la séquence parce que
tout le monde en a parlé et euh
pas forcément
j'avais quelque chose à faire et donc
j'ai tout de suite en rentrant j'ai
regardé et il se trouve que évidemment
en 38 ans de télévision quand même je
n'avais jamais vu une séquence pareille
elle était d'une force d'avoir
incroyable et ça prouve la liberté de
ton qui est dans cette émission certes
certes vous l'avez insulté vous n'auriez
pas dû parce que c'est un élu de la
République mais on comprend que vous
soyez poussé à bout parce qu'en fait ce
que vous avez vu chez lui c'était plutôt
le copain qui venait sur chroniqueur que
vous avez beaucoup aidé vous montrer
c'est le chroniqueur que vous avez vu
vous avez oublié ça fonctionne parce
qu'en fait vous vous en foutez de la
fonction dans le sens que pour vous les
politiques ne vous impressionnent pas et
que vous aviez oublié que c'était un
député parce que pour vous c'est pas
c'est pas c'était pas l'essentiel chez
vous la séquence était très forte et je
comprends tout à fait votre comportement
le sien bon évidemment c'est un gamin il
a 22 ans il a été élu je le redis grâce
à vous parce que c'est vraiment il a été
élu récemment et qui disent pas vous
l'avez fait une allusion là-dessus et il
a nié il vous dit est-ce que vous avez
voté pour moi enfin on reverra tout ça
et franchement c'est grâce à vous c'est
vous qui l'avez médiatisé et il doit
plutôt vous dire merci d'abord merci
d'avoir été dans cette émission pendant
des années et merci puisque c'est grâce
à lui grâce à vous que vous l'avez élu
député c'est vrai je le dis très
clairement c'est vrai et c'est une
tribune vous l'avez vous l'avez
médiatisé et rendez compte Google aussi
il y avait donné une tribune faut pas
l'oublier aussi on reviendra tout à
l'heure sur ce crédit
Olivier crucourt voilà qui lui aussi
voilà eu des petits des petits problèmes
avec lui
je pense c'était c'était Gil et
Géraldine aussi qui était je l'ai vu un
peu voilà j'ai vu très impliqué Benjamin
ah moi je pense que je suis votre ami et
quand j'ai vu la séquence d'ailleurs je
pense que vous avez plutôt gardé votre
calme vous connaissant un peu oui oui je
pense que globalement non mais
globalement j'ai même envoyé un texto
pendant l'émission froid et je le
pensais sincèrement après on est fait du
même bois et je comprends très bien ce
que des ressentis ça excuse pas les mots
un peu déplacé bon pour faire des bien
sûr mais je vous connais par cœur quand
on a quand on fait ce métier et quand on
tend la main aux gens c'est toujours
très compliqué et c'est extrêmement
blessant et heurtant d'avoir quelqu'un
on a alors aidé poussé
il a raison accompagné elle veut aussi
je trouve ça incroyable incroyable que
dans ce que dans ce monde il y a des
règles qui sont assez simples c'est
voilà il y a des choses qui ne se font
pas et je trouve que ce qu'il a fait là
il a le droit d'être dans ce parti
politique d'abord des convictions mais
ce qu'il a fait là c'est trahison de
c'est pas le propos c'est pas lui et je
vous connais un peu vous avez pas du
tout arrivé vu arriver le entre
guillemets le piège parce que c'était un
piège tout à l'heure mais j'ai trouvé ça
voilà j'étais triste pour vous trahi par
un ami et vous été trahis par un ami je
vous connais très bien contrairement à
ce que certains pensent Cyril Hanouna a
des principes et des il y a des valeurs
qui sont les siennes et qui sont
indestructibles voilà et j'ai trouvé ça
regrettable Valérie non mais que Cyril
moi je connais bien le Siri se soit
senti trahi et il met très très haut et
la relation d'amis et quand il donne sa
confiance il a le sentiment qui est que
voilà que c'est ou pour la vie ou pas du
tout et à ce moment-là il se sent
vraiment couteau dans le dos etc
maintenant moi je te l'ai dit Cyril au
téléphone c'est vrai que moi j'ai pas
j'ai absolument pas du tout aimé cette
séquence vraiment parce que je n'ai pas
aimé que tu
pour faire un buzz alors je sais après
en me renseignant que j'ai vu que la
première apparition qu'on avait
c'était dans le public pour faire un
buzz donc j'ai vu qu'il était habitué ce
genre de choses vous allez tout
comprendre dans un instant et je me suis
dit bon bah il est là pour faire du buzz
on va écouter ce qu'il a à dire parce
que là je trouve ça intéressant et là je
me suis rendu compte bah que je pense
que son écharpe lui avait monté à la
tête et c'était plus le petit Louis Le
Petit Louis pardon c'était plus c'est
quoi son prénom
que j'ai connu où on parlait ensemble on
parlait de la presse tous les deux et on
était hyper content de parler de la
Vendée et de notre de notre pays et en
fait c'était un petit gars qui qui avait
qui avait complètement buggé et qui qui
se la pétait avec son écharpe et qui
voulait juste faire un coup d'éclat et
j'ai trouvé ça bas j'ai trouvé ça nul
j'ai trouvé ça pas loyal j'ai trouvé ça
et puis devenir ici en plus pour le
faire là où il a commencé ben je me dis
le mec il est 100 fois ni loi et j'ai
trouvé ça pitoyable voilà
Guillaume moi j'étais très en colère
jeudi et je suis encore très en colère
j'ai trouvé ça inadmissible je trouve
que voilà quelqu'un qui vient sur ce
plateau pour déverser sa haine contre
vous je trouve ça dégueulasse c'est
quelqu'un qui vous avez fait confiance
c'est quelqu'un qui vous a trahi et
franchement j'ai trouvé que c'était un
manque de respect et encore une fois
voilà j'en ai marre de ces gens qui
viennent s'essuyer les pieds sur TPMP
pour faire bonne figures surtout quand
ces personnes étaient intervenants dans
cette émission était chroniqueur dans
cette émission donc Louis Boyard c'est
bien de dire que cette émission elle est
horrible et que c'est la pire émission
du monde n'oublie pas que tu étais
chroniqueur ici il y a encore quelques
semaines et tu étais bien content de
faire des toc toc toc et de mec des
perruques comme tout le monde dire quoi
que tu étais content de le faire donc
j'appelle ça de l'ingratitude et je
trouve ça dégueulasse voilà c'est tout
mais c'est vrai il est arrivé comme une
grenade dégoupillée et il a été
immédiatement insultant et agressif quoi
c'est à dire que sans sans avoir été
attaqué l'arrivée à fond quoi on va
parler dans un instant vous allez voir
on aura des députés aussi avec nous puis
je vais vous montrer tout les images
vous allez voir c'est c'est incroyable
parce que vous allez bien comprendre
Daniel moi je partage beaucoup de choses
évidemment j'ai été très peiné parce que
j'ai vu en vous une comme une bête
blessée j'avais envie de lécher vos
plaies parce que
que les fleurs il est possible ça c'est
ça c'est la plus mauvaise nouvelle de la
séquence
je suis interdit d'aller en dessous de
la ceinture et elle elle peluche vous
plaît
c'est vraiment j'ai vu un acte humain
j'ai vu j'ai vu une scène forte j'ai vu
un provocateur qui vraiment mais
dégoûtant quoi parce que avec des
accusations de racisme quand on vous
connaît quand on connaît l'émission
enfin des choses vraiment et tout le
temps dans l'insolence il a jamais
essayé de calmer le jeu alors que vous
même si vous êtes monté assez vite mais
parce que justement c'était à la hauteur
de votre déception humaine voilà j'ai vu
quelqu'un tout le temps dans la
provocation qui voilà qui est venu
exprès pour ça il a il a peut-être
réussi son coup il est peut-être content
et moi j'en suis très peiné de séquence
alors
avant qu'on est Géraldine et Gilles moi
il y a quelqu'un qui a eu qui a tenu à
réagir ce weekend
c'est français regardez
je l'aurais pris par la veste
dehors du plateau oui
s'énerver
[Musique]
député de quoi il est lui de la France
insoumise
il se rappelle pas qu'il a donné à
manger
il venait faire le
et maintenant il crache
surtout
l'attraper par la veste le jeter dehors
comme il fait ce guignolo au
gouvernement à kinsberg je vais aller me
présenter moi au gouvernement tu vas
voir
encore que l'autre là Verdez il
s'appelle le vieux encore qui a pas
donné tort parce que lui tu dis blanc il
dit rouge contrarie toujours
un peu
[Musique]
avec toi
elle est incroyable
elle est elle est incroyable je vous dis
français
elle est incroyable par contre le truc
qui m'a fait le plus de peine moi c'est
le comment il s'appelle le vieux
c'est le plus relou comment il s'appelle
le vieux ça c'est peut-être région
Géraldine oui alors déjà je trouve que
c'est pas évident quand on a des
goupillé ou quand on a vrillé ou quand
on a insulté quelqu'un de regretter
qu'il fallait pas le faire donc déjà
c'est pas mal donc je trouve que vous
avez insulté voilà l'insulte
pour que c'est nous malgré tout dans
cette émission on dit toujours que voilà
il faut pas insulter il faut pas injurer
donc je trouve ça vraiment plutôt
costaud et courageux après une sorte
comme une peine de cœur vous avez été
trahi en fait c'est un des pieds
amoureux de Goya à partir du moment non
mais il a pas été loyal donc en fait il
a été tellement grave face à quelqu'un
de totalement ingrat et de pas du tout
loyal quand je dis une peine de coeur
c'est à dire en fait voilà vous êtes
centrale cocu d'une certaine manière ou
en gros il vient ici il a croqué pendant
deux ans il connaît parfaitement le
système et à partir de ce moment-là
voilà il fait son happning mais moi je
pense que tout est prémédité tout est
calculé il y a rien il y a rien qui est
mystérieux donc voilà apprend connais
vos emportements on connaît comment
comment dire on sait à quel point vous
avez le sens de la famille donc en fait
où on est avec vous mais on n'est pas
avec vous et c'est à partir du moment où
on a été avec vous on peut pas lui n'est
pas légitime pour venir ici pour dire ça
n'importe qui aurait pu venir s'il
n'avait pas travailler avec vous c'est
ça et puis qu'il aille ailleurs pour en
parler mais voilà donc je l'ai trouvé
comment dire en fait il veut couper les
têtes il Boyard il est pas là pour
parler il est pas là pour dialoguer il
veut couper la tête de TPMP il veut
couper la tête de serrer la Nouna
méprise c'est un enfant de la télé c'est
un enfant de la télé c'est un enfant du
buzz quand vous avez dit tout à l'heure
il était au GG les GG il est quitte la
veille alors qu'ils avaient annoncé
Louis Boyard dans leur plaquettes il est
quitte la veille qui dit moi j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] je préfère aller chez
Cyril Hanouna il y a plus de visibilité
je vais être plus populaire et je vais
être plus vite dans la lumière donc en
termes d'ingratitude en fait on n'est
pas on peut pas être plus loin que le
Boyard donc voilà donc en fait il a
voulu faire votre dos voilà donc en fait
après je pense tu as raison et puis
Géraldine moi jouer c'est à toi parce
que c'est vrai que j'ai un line on est
on est souvent on s'engueule on peut
s'engueuler dans l'émission tout ça et
c'est vrai Géraldine elle le voit et
elle le sait Matthieu aussi quand je
reviendrai dessus quand on touche à mes
amis ça vous est déjà arrivé aussi c'est
vrai que voilà Jean-Marie je l'ai dit
ce sera toujours le cas et s'il arrive
quelque chose à Géraldine je serai le
premier à le défendre aussi elle le sait
mais voilà
c'est ça des moments qui étaient plutôt
tendus entre nous et ça ne change rien
et voilà donc
Gilou qui a lui a été très peiné je sais
pas si tu l'as eu toi j'étais senti
vraiment parce que je t'ai vu après
l'émission tu étais le plus triste dans
les couloirs il était dans les couloirs
il parlait pas j'avais l'impression
qu'il allait rejoindre samoya que la
vérité
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression que sa vérité tu es au
bout du couloir j'ai vu Gilles j'ai mais
qu'est-ce qui agile parce que voilà et
moi je lui dis mais calme-toi frérot ça
va t'inquiète pas tout ça et c'est vrai
que voilà après moi je suis allé manger
avec des amis euh
avec ce délinquants et c'est vrai que
voilà on a pensé à toi dis moi s'il me
regarde là encore ils sont là-bas voilà
ils sont derrière cachés toujours
toujours peur d'être recherché alors que
c'est fini tout ça voilà oui Gilles j'ai
été très marqué c'est vrai et j'en ai
encore gros sur le cœur alors d'abord
j'ai été marqué parce que j'ai pas
reconnu Louis Boyard Louis Boyard
c'était un peu mon de la moustache
c'était un peu non pas mon mon complice
mais on parlait beaucoup avant les
émissions on partage les mêmes valeurs
on partage les mêmes valeurs de gauche
je suis à gauche très à gauche je
voulais toujours dit donc on avait un
terrain commun et puis Louis quand il
venait aux émissions il adorait venir il
aime le micro il a toujours aimé ça en
coulisse je l'encourageais je lui
parlais et je me souviens de quelques
fois alors il est pas mort
non parce que là mon esprit il l'est un
peu je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
parce que quand il était en coulisse et
parfois vous savez vous faites sauter
des séquences parce qu'on a pas le temps
et parfois il passait pas et il disait
j'espère revenir demain Gilles tu penses
que je reviendrai j'ai mais oui oui t'es
bon tu reviendras jamais il me disait oh
là là il y a trop de gens d'extrême
droite oh là là je peux pas m'exprimer
il était toujours tout content voilà et
là d'un coup je trouve qu'il a beaucoup
changé et c'est plus Louis Boyard j'ai
l'impression que le costume de député la
Transformer je me demande s'il est pas
un peu trop grand pour lui en tout cas
je n'ai pas reconnu Louis Boyard ça
c'est ma peine personnelle mais ça c'est
rien là où je suis révolté c'est ce
qu'il vous a fait parce que dire que
vous faites vous Cyril le jeu de
l'extrême droite que vous faites monter
le racisme ou que
vous vous ne partagez pas des valeurs de
tolérance alors que le combat de votre
vie c'est contre le racisme contre
l'antisémitisme contre toutes les
discriminations vous faites parler tout
le monde liberté de parole une immense
tolérance et lui il vient et pourtant ça
en trois mots mal choisis en plus ça ça
me laisse un goût totalement amer et
nous dire ici à nous tous qu'on a pas la
liberté de parole alors que c'est la
reine la plus libre que j'ai jamais
connue j'ai été dans beaucoup de médias
comme dirait français je suis vieux mais
j'ai été dans beaucoup de médias et je
peux vous donner des tas d'exemples de
censure plein ici jamais jamais moi on
m'a dit quoi que ce soit évidemment vous
jamais monsieur Bolloré jamais personne
ne m'a dit tais-toi me dis pas ça donc
Boyard il a trahi non seulement l'amitié
que j'avais on s'en fout mais le respect
que j'avais pour lui et ça je lui
pardonnerai jamais Cyril c'est pour ça
que ça m'a bouleversé cette séquence et
vous avez vous vous en c'est pas le
problème et puis vous êtes au-dessus de
ça mais je voulais vous dire que vous
avez mon soutien total
est-ce qu'a fait Louis Boyard c'est
dégueulasse je te le pardonnerai pas
alors
[Applaudissements]